[Music]
the Department of Justice has uncovered
a sprawling College Admission scandal
while condemnation has justifiably
rained down on the rich parents who paid
bribes the colleges in question are
equally culpable college staff were
complicit in these schemes or asleep at
the switch these same colleges won't
abolish legacy admissions or stop
reserving seats for the kids of big
donors if admissions offices can't
detect corruption and colleges can't
stop selling access maybe colleges can't
be trusted to judge merit fairly so
here's a modest proposal elite colleges
can put their money where their mouth is
when they talk about democratizing
opportunity take a page out of the k-12
charter school playbook and switch to
lottery admissions any applicant with a
high school credential would have an
equal shot at admission admittedly this
would be a huge blow to the prestige of
elite colleges are paying for corporate
HR departments and a giant bummer for
the college prep industry but I think
we'd survive how do you think we should
reform college admissions let us know in
the comments also let us know what other
topics you'd like our scholars to cover
in 60 seconds and be sure to LIKE and
subscribe for more research and videos
from AEI